التفكير بالاتجاه للطاقه البديله لم يكن
وليد اللحظه عند السيد اديب فمنذ اكثر من
12 عاما اتجه الى طاقه الشمس لتوليد
الكهرباء واليوم يعتمد السيد اديب على
الطاقه النظيفه في استخداماته 100%
متجاوزا ازمه ارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء
خلال ثلاث سنوات هذول طبعا انا لانه
استخدام عالي بيت كبير ومع الاسوار ومع
البوابات ومع استخدام ومعتمد على الكهرباء
احنا وفرنا بما يقارب حوالي 20.000 دينار
خلال ثلاث سنوات الماضي
على طاقه الشمس والرياح بما يقارب 29% من
الطاقه المولده ظروف الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
تدفع الولاده لضروره استغلال الموارد
الطبيعيه المتجدده لتخفيف استيرادها من
الخارج فهنا واحد من اكبر المجمعات
الشمسيه في المنطقه اضافه لمشروع طاقه
الرياح في دوله تسعى الاعتماد الطاقه
البديله بدعمها تكلفه انظمه الخلايا
الشمسيه للقطاع المنزلي والسياحي والصناعي
بنسبه تصلوا الى خمسينات
اثر اقتصادي واجتماعي مباشر على المواطنين
ومساعدتهم على تحمل فاتوره الكهرباء
الشهريه ورغم الحاجه الملحه لرفع قدره
الشبكات والخطوط المولده للطاقه الشمسيه
الا ان طبيعه الاردن الجغرافيه المناسبه
لمشاريع الطاقه النظيفه اضافه لكونه واحدا
من دول الحزام الشمسي كانت دافعه لاستغلال
موارده غير مكلفه وسط ازمه عالميه ضاعفت
من قيمه فاتوره الكهرباء
سوها جميل العربيه عمان